(swooshing)
- Good morning, Believe
Nation, I'm Evan Carmichael,
my One Word is Believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
I started the Believe Life
Series to try to step outside
just the world of entrepreneurship,
and learn from different
areas to try to help us become
better, more well rounded individuals
who can go out and have a big impact.
So in today's episode,
we're going to learn
how you can travel the world.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And always guys, as you're watching,
if someone says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it down for yourself,
it's much more likely to
stick for you as well, enjoy.
(bouncy music)
- What is it about new places
that attracts us to them?
We thirst to wander,
explore, and discover.
What drives us to fly around
the world to touch a wall?
To find our likes, and our dislikes?
It's in our veins, it's human nature,
that drives us farther,
that pushes us higher,
that shows us who we
are and breaks us free.
(inspirational music)
Once you've touched the world,
you've changed yours forever.
(kids laughing)
It's a craving that exists in all of us
which leaves you with only one option,
pick a place...
Wow, that looks amazing.
You buy a ticket...
- Can I book a one way
ticket to Thailand please?
- [Kristen] You pack a bag,
make a plan,
and you go again.
(high pitched chiming)
- If you have a dream, if
you have this crazy idea,
you must believe in it
even if no one else does.
So when I had the idea to go
to every country in the world,
that's kind of what it felt like,
it felt like this crazy idea.
It was like, this just sounds
like totally ridiculous
and absurd, but I couldn't
stop thinking about it.
And I realized that if I didn't pursue it,
I would always regret it.
And that knowledge, that fear of regret,
kind of drove me to say yes.
And I talked to lots of other people
who used very similar language,
there's a guy from Portland, Maine
whose crazy idea was
to walk across America,
and he wasn't even sure
how does that work?
How much time does it take?
Has anyone ever done this before?
It was this crazy idea that
wouldn't leave him alone.
And so one morning, he
left his home in Maine,
and he started walking, and
seven and a half months later
he arrived in San Francisco.
And I talked to him
throughout the whole journey,
I talked to him at the
beginning, and the middle
and the end, and I asked him
what were the challenges like?
How did it go, and he said,
he said something that stayed with me
for the rest of my journey,
he said, you know, there are
lots of external challenges.
It was hard on the body to
get used to walking that much,
lots of things went wrong.
There were some emotional
challenges as well,
he just had a breakup, and he was kind of
processing all of this.
He said what I realized
about two weeks in,
once I stopped complaining and grumbling
about the whole thing,
he said I realized that
my task was pretty simple.
All I had to do was walk, essentially,
and if I did nothing else,
if I got up every morning
and I made a little bit of progress,
then eventually I would reach the goal.
Eventually I would
arrive in San Francisco,
and achieve that goal,
reach that destination.
And it sounded really simple.
But it's kind of stayed with me
for the final two years of
my quest because that's how
I felt it was for me too.
All I had to do was get to 193 countries,
and I had my list of countries.
And I was making progress,
and if I got stuck somewhere,
eventually I'd have to
overcome that challenge
but I could go and do some others first.
And I liked the logical,
analytical progress of it.
It's something that related
to me so, just keep going,
you have to believe in your dream
even if no one else does.
- [Caty] Let me give you the
basics of what I personally did
to travel for nearly three
months, financially speaking.
First I picked my destination
and bought my plane tickets.
In this particular case, it
was actually cheaper for me
to buy a one way ticket to New York City
and then a one way ticket
from New York to Berlin
with a stopover in Oslo
than it was for me to buy
a one way ticket directly
from Las Vegas to Berlin
with any stopovers.
So although it added a little bit of time
to my itinerary, I saved
a couple hundred dollars.
My favorite website for buying
tickets is Google.com/flights
because it shows you both on
a map and in calendar format
the specific days as well as the airports
it would be cheapest to fly into.
If you're somebody who always
goes for the cheapest flights,
this is the best tool that
I have personally found.
And if you're the more adventurous type
with no specific destination
in mind, skyscanner.com
is a fantastic option simply
because they literally
have the option to search
for anywhere on the globe.
So for example, let's say
that you are available
at some point during the month of March,
but you don't know when
yet, and you're available
to go anywhere but you don't
know where you want to go.
On Skyscanner, you can
literally select an entire month
that you would want to
travel at some point during,
and you can actually select
the Everywhere option
when you're searching for a destination.
So doing it this way will
show you the cheapest
place to fly on the planet
during the entire month of March
to travel to from your
specific destination.
So if you're the adventurous
type, I highly recommend,
it's fantastic.
Once I bought my plane
tickets, I researched
a little bit of what I wanted to do
in the specific countries I was going to.
For me, I personally love
museums, learning about history,
and the occasional nice meal.
I also knew that I would
be traveling by train
between countries, and I
would be staying primarily
in hostels, so I pretty much just Googled
a little bit of what I
wanted to do in each country,
got a price range for
those specific activities,
added it up and multiplied
it by the number of days
I would be traveling.
This was my basic budget.
Due to the fact that I'd
be traveling through Europe
during the high season,
it can get expensive.
So just to be safe, I upped
my daily budget to $100 a day.
Yes, this is a lot of money,
no you don't need to do this.
I ended up spending, on
average, way under $100 a day.
But it was comforting
knowing that I had a little
extra wiggle room in my budget
in case anything came up.
I highly recommend giving
yourself a daily budget,
no matter what it is,
during the entire time
that you're traveling.
A daily budget, in my personal
opinion is a lot easier
to keep in the back of your head,
than an overarching budget that spans
for weeks and weeks and weeks on end.
- For water when we went
to Central America or Asia,
we used to buy a lot of bottled water,
and we felt really bad about
it, it was a lot of plastic,
and it was actually really expensive.
So now we got ourselves
a really small portable
water purifier, this one's a Steripen.
You can charge it with USB
and it works really well.
It's just an ultraviolet
light that kills the bacteria.
And we basically just fill up
our water bottle with water,
you turn it on, put it in here and stir it
for about a minute, and your water's clean
and ready to drink.
- For food and snacks,
we usually tried to bring
our own stuff because food at the airport
and the train station, and
basically any touristy area
is usually overpriced
and really expensive.
So we'll usually pack
a bag of our own snacks
so that we can save
money, and also make sure
that we have the food that
we actually like to eat.
It's important to check out
the different guidelines
for where you're going because
they're always changing
and often you can't bring
things like produce,
liquids, raw nuts and things like that.
Packing our food is also
a great way to make sure
that we're eating healthy
food which we can't
always find when we're on the move.
- For staying clean we have
a few really simple things
that we use and that
work really well for us.
One of our favorite things
is this laundry soap bar.
We use this to wash our clothes by hand.
It is nice to be independent
and be able to do that
almost wherever you are.
And it saves us a lot of money
'cause we don't have to go to laundromats.
Another thing we carry around
with us is dry shampoo.
I was very skeptical of this when Danielle
first talked about it
but it actually works
really, really well.
It's just a little powder
that you put in your hand,
you mix it around in
your hair, and it's like
you washed your hair,
you kind of get a little
refresher in between showers.
You can buy this, but
you can also look it up
and make your own using
pretty simple ingredients
like corn starch.
And another thing that we bring with us
almost all the time and it helps us deal
with those days in between
showers are wet wipes.
We obviously don't bring
a big container like this.
But wet wipes combined
with the dry shampoo
are a really great simple,
portable way to stay clean
on long travel days and between showers.
And last, we always bring
our trusty Dr Bronners soap.
This can be used for
anything, it's natural,
it's unscented, so we can wash dishes,
we can shower with this.
So it's really, really handy.
If you're traveling outside the country,
you're obviously going
to need your passport,
and you're going to need to
take really good care of it.
We got ours stolen once
and we just had one
that was ruined by water damage.
And if there's just a bit of water that
smudges the picture, it's invalid.
So you got to take really good care of it
because if something happens
when you're in another country,
then it's really
expensive to get a new one
and it's a lot of trouble.
So what we do now is that
we always carry it in
a traveling pouch,
sometimes in a pouch that
we can hide on our selves,
and in that pouch we also keep
the passport in a Ziploc bag.
It's really simple, it costs nothing.
And it'll save it from
getting water damage.
- Number four, work remotely.
These days certain jobs
can be done from anywhere.
Whether it's programming
to graphic design,
or freelance writing and photography.
Websites like Upwork
can help you find work
as a freelancer or hire other freelancers
to help you take your show on the road.
The key is geo arbitrage, earning money
in a strong currency and spending it
where life's a little bit
cheaper, think Southeast Asia.
A good resource to learn
more is Timothy Ferriss'
4-Hour Workweek, seriously, read the book.
- Make sure you can make money remotely.
If you can't make money remotely,
if that's just not really within
your reach, or your grasp,
the other very obvious option
is get a job somewhere else.
Whatever you're doing at home,
somebody else in the world
somewhere else will have a use for it.
It doesn't really matter,
you can do that job
somewhere else, granted
you might get paid less.
You could work in a hostel
where you get room and board
and some spending money, and
get to hang out with people
and do cool activities,
as an example, right?
- Some examples of people
that we met who are doing this
lifestyle, living indefinitely
were workers at hostels.
In Nicaragua we met a handful of friends
that had been there for
years, like literally,
two, three, four, five years,
and that's all they do,
they live on the beach,
they have this beautiful
lifestyle in paradise.
Granted, they don't
have a lot of luxuries,
as you can call it that
we would have back home.
- They have usually a simpler lifestyle.
You have somewhat OK wifi,
you have a room that's nothing grandiose.
You might not have a house
or a car that you own.
You have a bungalow on the beach
and you have a little
scooter to rip around in.
You've got coconuts in
front and you've got
hammocks on the ocean.
But that's some people's vacation.
Some people work year round
to get two weeks of that.
Why don't you just flip the
switch a little bit, right?
- I met a girl in Thailand
who essentially had been to
15 countries, and all
she did was would go,
work at the hostel for a month or so,
she'd make a few hundred dollars,
that would be enough to
take her to the next city,
next country, she'd work
there, she'd work at a bar.
- It's not difficult is what we're saying.
A lot of people do it, a lot
of very young people do it.
Some people just don't
want to go to university,
they do that, they figure out, oh (muting)
a lot of people are doing
this, and it's pretty simple.
And I met a lot of new friends
and just kind of go with it.
- Hopefully it's inspired you in some way.
What we really want to get
out of this is to teach you
and to help you guys understand
that travel is for everyone.
You don't have to be rich to travel.
- No, no, no.
- You just have to be smart,
you need to understand
the world of travel because you can do it
with a small amount of money.
You can do it in a huge way
And do it forever if you do it right.
- You don't have to be rich to travel.
Actually, all expenses
while you're traveling
fall into three major categories.
First is transportation to
get from point A to point B.
The other thing is
accommodation, and the last
is everything else,
food, drinks and so on.
If you minimize those three
expenses to some minimum,
it can be actually cheaper to travel
than live in your own city.
For the next five years
I've been traveling
around the world with almost no money.
And this is how I did it.
First thing, I hitchhiked.
Apart from being free, apart
from being really fast,
it allowed me one amazing
thing, to have an adventure
between point A and point B.
How many of you guys have ever hitchhiked?
Maybe, OK, oh quite a lot.
Why, (laughing) what are you doing?
OK.
(audience laughing)
I'm going to play you a short
video called Hitchhiking Guide
just to tell you a few unwritten
rules about hitchhiking
and some of my experiences.
("All My Days" by Alexi Murdoch)
When it comes to hitchhiking,
everything is about
using common sense.
First, to start, you have
to get out of the cities
or villages or wherever you live and
(mumbling) so you have
to be on the right road,
going in the right direction and
it's really basic things.
Lesson number two, stick up your thumb.
Probably most of you
have it so just do this.
♫ I have been searching
Hitchhiking lesson number 36,
Look decent like,
shave and stuff.
And try to wear some
clean clothes whatever,
or hide behind your backpack,
so nobody sees what you look like.
Lesson number 54,
do not hitchhike during night.
Be in a good mood.
It's your choice, you're
hitchhiking, you chose this so
don't be grumpy, don't be like (whining).
Lesson number 58, eye
contract with the drivers.
See, this one nearly stopped.
Yeah, don't hitchhike alone.
I have a friend that I hitchhike with.
Meet Maria Juana, this is sheep.
Lesson number 21,
talk with the drivers
when you're in the car
'cause that's the only
way you can repay them.
They would like to hear
some interesting stories
if you have one, yeah?
If not, just listen to their
story, that's sometimes enough.
Lesson number nine!
Fasten your seat belt if you have one.
Hitchhiking lesson number 62,
when driver is asleep, take over.
Be always happy, you know like,
you're hitchhiking, it's your choice.
Sometimes you have to wait.
Be patient and don't expect
people will stop 'cause
you'll be wrong at 99.74% of cases.
But, no matter how long you wait,
the right driver will come, so,
that's the ultimate hitchhiking rule,
and that's all you have to know, man.
There are no rules actually,
(bleep) all the rules.
So...
Yeah go out there, enjoy your life and
challenge yourself, eh?
♫ Feels all right
♫ Now even breathing feels all right
♫ Yes even breathing
(honking)
♫ Feels all right
When it comes to accommodation
most of the time I use Couchsurfing
because I had a lot of
experience, I had a lot of these
positive references on
the website and so on,
and what I like about
Couchsurfing the most
is not only because it's
free, it allows you to
have a different perspective
of the destination.
You're not destined to
stay in your hotel room
or take the tourist tours, you
just hang out with your host,
he takes you on places
that you would probably
never visit by yourself.
In rich cities, in rich
countries, I usually
buy food in supermarkets
which is the cheapest way
and just eat on the street.
You can also cook with your
host which can be pretty
unique experience to say the least.
These are Germans actually. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
Sorry!
(laughing) It was pretty
delicious to say the least.
And one of the cheapest.
One other thing when it comes to traveling
is that you can earn money
while you're traveling.
How to do that? I did it couple of times.
One of them is busking, playing
the guitar on the street.
I'm not a musician, I know like probably
four, five chords and four songs.
So it's like repeat all,
people are passing by so
they don't really know.
(audience laughing)
But the most important
thing is to have a story.
I always had my small
card board which I wrote,
actually somebody else
wrote in the local language
where I'm from, what I'm
doing there, what's my story.
And I think that's why people donated
a little bit of money, some
sandwiches, sodas, and so on.
You won't earn a lot
of money by doing this,
but it can get you through the day.
One other way is to write.
You can write a blog,
open up a Facebook page,
after a while you can maybe
write a book, and so on.
Is it for everyone,
this type of traveling?
I don't think so.
With all the amazing things that
this kind of traveling can bring to you,
there are also downsides.
It's a big chance that you will be lonely,
that you will be hungry,
that you will be sick,
that you will be homesick.
But, it all comes down
to your gut feeling.
If, after all these ideas
and all these knowledges,
you still have that, wow, I
wish I could travel like this,
then you should definitely do it.
Then you should forget about your fears,
disregard the fact that you're broke,
and just leave, head to the road.
Because, like that famous quote says,
in 20 years from now on, you
will be more disappointed
by the things you didn't do
than by the things you did do.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video?
What was the biggest
takeaway that you're going to
immediately apply somehow in your life?
Or maybe your business, let me know,
leave it down in the comments below,
really curious to find out.
I also wanted to give a quick
shout out to Wesley Lavinder
from fullyoptimized.org,
Wesley thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
and offering to do a review on it,
I really appreciate the support man,
and I'm glad you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you have an amazing
day, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever Your One Word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(swooshing, basketball bouncing)
- [Woman] We all have
these great ideas, right?
And at the same time we
have responsibilities
and mortgages and whatever.
So I guess I'm just
wondering what your advice is
to people who want to go out
and pursue certain things
but there're also certain
limitations I guess
that we have to exist within.
I guess we don't, but I
can't walk away from my condo
tomorrow and walk across the country,
it probably wouldn't work
out well for me. (laughing)
- That's a great question,
but do you want to walk
across the country?
Is that your aspiration?
(laughing)
I'm a big fan of defining our aspirations
and then crafting our life
around them essentially.
And so like the quest
to visit every country
in the world for example,
I was thinking about this
the other day 'cause people
ask how much it cost, right?
And the first 100 countries
cost about $30,000.
So 30,000, at least I would argue
is not a huge amount of money
for going to 100 countries
and all the life experience
that I got through that.
And also I didn't have
to pay it all right away.
You pay as you go, essentially
in something like that.
So...
These limitations as you said,
maybe let's not call them limitations,
they're responsibilities.
Especially people with
families like you don't just
leave your family and
walk across the country.
But, again there are ways to cultivate
the value of adventure,
that's why I like the story
of Sasha and what she did at home.
There's a woman in Omaha
who's knitting 10,000 hats.
And her passion, the thing
that she really loved
was always knitting, and one
Christmastime or holiday time
she made 100 hats for
her friends and family.
And she was like, that's really fun.
I want to do 1000, but 1000
is not a big enough challenge
so she took on this goal of 10,000 hats.
And there's a charity component to it.
You can connect with her on her website
and eventually get a hat.
So, I mean I don't know,
responsibilities and things
are real, but if something
matters to us, I guess I'm also
a believer in figuring
out how to do that, right?
Like we do have to trade off things.
We do have to sacrifice.
And especially for all of us
with so many opportunities
available to us, it's a
matter of prioritization.
It's a matter of,
I can probably do anything I
want but I can't do everything.
Right, so, if this thing
really does matter to me
whether it's walking across the country
or whatever it is in your case,
then it's something that
you have to plan for
and build for and for me
it was worth it to do that.
- I have a small story, short
story about these prejudices
that I encountered while I was traveling.
When I was leaving Croatia and heading
on my round the world trip,
everybody was telling me, be careful.
It's very dangerous,
you're going to hitchhike,
you're going to sleep
in other peoples' homes,
and stuff like that.
In Croatia it's still
OK to travel you know,
but as soon as you cross the
border, enter into Serbia,
you know what Serbians are like, you know?
Be very, very careful,
somebody might kill you.
And I'm like OK, thank
you for the warning,
and I crossed the border,
enter into Serbia,
amazing adventures, amazing people I met,
people picking me up taking me out,
sleeping in their homes really,
really amazing experiences.
And I was leaving Serbia,
heading to Bulgaria,
I was driving with one
driver and telling him
that story like how
Croatians were warning me
about Serbians, and he's like, ah brother,
that's complete nonsense,
Croatians and Serbians
we're all brothers, but
Bulgarians, (groaning).
(audience laughing)
When you cross the border,
enter into Bulgaria
you know what Bulgarians are like,
lot of Gypsies man, you know?
Be very careful, somebody might kill you.
(audience laughing)
And I entered Bulgaria the
same story all over again.
Amazing experiences, people
were just extremely friendly.
And then I was driving
with one truck driver,
going towards Turkey and I was
telling him the same story,
how Croatians warn me about Serbia,
and Serbians about Bulgarians,
and he's like ah brother,
you know, that's complete nonsense.
Croatians, Serbians, Bulgarians,
we're all Balkan brothers.
But Turkish people, oh my God!
You know what Turkish people are like?
Very dangerous, somebody might kill you.
Turkish people warned
me about Kurdish people,
Kurdish people about Iranis,
Iranis about Pakistanis,
Pakistanis about Indians.
Indians didn't warn me about anyone.
(audience laughing)
It's like they're the last
frontier or something.
Beats me.
But yeah.
It wasn't only a travel
lesson, but maybe a life lesson
like not to trust all these horror stories
people were telling.
- And my last, probably most obscure tip
is changing your relationship with money.
I'm going to be a little bit harsh here.
If the biggest problem
in your life right now
is saving money to travel,
you are pretty damn lucky.
Think about all of the other
problems you could be having
in your life, family
problems, health problems,
not having enough money to put
food on the table problems.
Those are actual legitimate problems.
Being bummed because you can't travel
is a pretty awesome problem to have.
And once you start
seeing it as a privilege
to have that problem as opposed
to this crippling reason
of why you can't travel,
you can start simplifying
money in your life and figuring out ways
to get what you want.
If you want to save money to
travel you have two options,
spend less or make more.
We talked about how to figure
out what your overhead is
and your take home, so
start looking through things
that you can cut out of your daily life
so you can save more to travel.
And if you don't want to cut
out going out with your friends
and drinking lattes, then that's fine,
but that just means now you
need to make more money.
Can you pick up another job?
When I realized that I want
to be able to quit my job
to travel the world, I needed to save up
a lot of money really
quick, and I knew that
there was no way I was
going to be able to do that
with my current job as a surf instructor,
so I picked up a bartending job at night
and then I picked up a job
being a brand ambassador
for a natural soap
company on the weekends.
I was working all the time.
Not only that, but then
I started cutting back
on all of my daily expenses.
I moved into a cheaper apartment,
I stopped drinking and eating out,
I did absolutely everything I
could to minimize my overhead
and maximize my take home.
If your dream is to
travel, then that's the way
you can do it too.